Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.
How are you guys doing? I recently came
across a video or an interview between
Nick Fuentes, who's a white nationalist
who's gained prominence, and Piers
Morgan. Um, the video has gotten
considerable traction since it's been
released yesterday. About 2 million, I
think, views now. And it was interesting
actually because it was an exchange
which both men had their moments. Now I
don't have a dog in the race because I'
I've debated Pers Morgan himself. I've
debated his friends Dersuits and so on
and I've been very hostile in fact in my
engagements with them. Uh Nick Fuentes
in fact we have a mutual friend who Sneo
um his views are things we don't agree
with but nevertheless as an individual I
don't have any personal grudge against
this guy. Um, this is going to be some
kind of a debate, say
analysis. Since I'm somebody who's a
neutral observer, I think it's fair for
someone like me to be doing the
analysis. In my estimation, Piers
Morgan, okay, had his moments. Let's
take a look at the first clip and come
back and respond in kind.
>> But you mentioned Mexico in that list.
Um, and your father is is half Mexican.
So yeah, I mean by your criteria, part
of the invasion would include your
father presumably and his immediate
descendants who came from Mexico.
>> Not really true because when my father's
ancestors came here, it was a small
fraction of the total immigrants that
came from Mexico. I don't believe that
we should have zero immigrants forever
or even zero immigrants from non-white
countries. But you have to draw the
distinction. My my father's father, he
was here in the in the 40s and 50s. It
was his parents or I believe either his
parents or grandparents that came here
even earlier. Up until 1965,
90% of the immigrants were coming from
Europe. I have no problem with that. If
we have 10% of them coming from Mexico
or Latin America, maybe that's
reasonable. But that's not what it is
now. Now you've got 10 million illegals
in four years under Joe Biden. uh and
you got millions more legal immigrants
from China, India, Venezuela. Now,
>> as you can see with that, clearly Piers
Morgan had Nick Fuentes on the back
foot. Okay? Uh because Nick Fuentes now
was starting to to create exemptions and
exceptions for the case of immigration.
Now, of course, he wants to defend his
father, which is was an honorable thing.
Of course, he's personally attached and
emotionally attached to his father, but
now he's starting to water down and
dilute his anti-immigration stance. Oh,
10% or something like that will be from
Mexico and that happens to be the 10%
that includes your father. Okay?
[laughter]
I mean, I mean this you cannot if you
are a Nick Fuentes supporter, you cannot
seriously think that he was doing well.
At least in this segment of this
discussion, he was not. Piers Morgan had
him on the back foot. He was asking
questions which were touchy, personal.
Um, and Fuentes actually went on after
this segment that you've just seen to
kind of um, you know, bring us back up a
little bit and and get a little bit
touchy and get a little bit sensitive on
these issues. As I've mentioned, he
wasn't emboldened and striden as he
usually is when he's talking about
immigration. Now the Mexicans have
become reasonable subjects, have they?
Because your father is one of them. This
certainly was, I think, a point of
contradiction, at least internal
contradiction. Now, Fuentes could have
responded and said, "Well, even if I'm a
hypocrite in this regard, this would be
a tukqui fallacy. You're appealing to
hypocrisy, which is an informal logical
fallacy, and it doesn't matter what my
personal situation is." And he could
have de-individualized himself from the
whole thing and said it's irrelevant
what my father is or who he is. My views
are such and such. He could have gone
down that kind of sober cold rational
route. But um he didn't unfortunately.
And uh Pier had him on that round.
However, Nick Fuentes has also had his
moments to be fair. And Pierers Borggan
does this thing where he to put it in
Nick's terms plays dumb. Let's take a
look at the next clip and respond in
kind. Two twothirds of mass shootings at
school perpetrated by white people.
>> But what proportion of white men commit
school shootings? That's a question.
>> I've just told you it's 60 or 65% of
school shootings by white.
>> You're telling me what proportion of
school shootings are committed by white
people? I'm saying what proportion of
white people have committed school
shootings. Are you playing dumb or are
you just not that smart?
>> What difference does that make to the to
the children lying dead on the ground?
>> See, now you want to jump on the
victims. The difference is you're asking
would you fear white people
>> or black people? And that's the
difference. The difference is what I'm
saying to you is by yourility by your
logic if if we now have agreed that the
vast majority of mass shootings in
schools are committed by white people
and predominantly young white men, then
presumably your advice would be to avoid
young white men because people betray
these. But he won't be because they're
white, right?
>> So, so are you playing dumb or are you
actually dumb? It's about
proportionality. You are. You are
because you're Well, I don't think you
are dumb. I think you're smart,
actually. But you're deliberately
avoiding per capita. And everybody knows
that's the difference. What proportion
of white men are school shooters? It's
probably 0
1%. What proportion of black men have
committed violent crimes? It's probably
like 5%. I get I don't know what it is
off the top of my head, but it's very
high. And I would add to that, even as
it concerns schools, why do you think
parents pay a super high property tax to
live in a school district where there's
white people? Because they know that if
they go to the black school, it's going
to be the Bloods and the Crips. It's
going to be gangs. It's going to be, you
know, you talk about school shootings.
Nobody talks about all the school
shootings that are committed by
gangbangers in and around the school and
all the other violence that's associated
with that. I mean these these schools in
the south side of Chicago, you know,
it's just not enough.
>> Now, as you can see here, this is the
argument that Nick Fuentes is making.
Says, look, you got the population of
the United States of America, right? You
got this many black people, you've got
this many white people, and black people
disproportionately commit murder uh to
white people. Okay? And there's some
truth in that claim. Of course, there is
some truth in that claim. there's a
disproportionality in the amount of
African-American
uh murderers versus white murderers. But
there are two things that are missing in
this equation. And this is what Pierce
should have really done because what he
did himself no favors by talking about
the high school shooters and stuff like
that. This was a false analysis because
why are you analyzing or comparing and
contrasting one aspect of murder with
murder as a whole anyway? But the point
is they kept talking about fearing the
other. Okay? And this is the word that
fuente has used. This is the word that
is being mentioned that basically how
much right do we have to fear the other
fear a black man or fear a white man.
Now the response could have been from
Pierers Morgan as follows. He could have
said look at how many wars the United
States of America has been in since its
inception. Okay. Now why is war
exempt from this analysis? Murder is
murder. When murder is done in a state
of war, it's a sanctioned murder, state
sanctioned murder. It doesn't stop it
from being murder. So when Americans go
to Iraq or go to North Korea, go to
South Korea, go to whatever it may be,
Afghanistan and kill people,
how many people in that army are white
and how many people in that army are
black? Okay. Now, you might want to
absolve yourself and say, "Well, this is
a false analysis and whatever." But who
gets to choose where the goalpost will
be when we're talking about murder.
There's an arbitrariness in the argument
that's made here, which is unjustified
by Nick Fuentes. So, if he wants to talk
about murder, then he has to include
wars. And if he includes wars, then
white people are disproportionately
higher than black people. In fact,
they're disproportionately higher than
everybody else in the world in the last
100 years. Look at World War I and look
at World War II. If you want to talk
about black-on-black crime, okay, in
America, for example, black-on-black
crime, yes, it's something which we need
to look at and something which we need
to work on in communities and something
which there shouldn't be uh a
relinquishing or a diffusion of the
responsibility.
There shouldn't. And that's another
extreme, okay, which some communities of
ethnics or whatever find it very
sensitive to talk about the fact that
there are things that have to do in
their communities. That's another
extreme, okay? And we're not advocating
that extreme. Okay? Either we are saying
that if you want to make a race realist
argument, then you have to factor in all
of the variables. And unfortunately with
your analysis, Mr. Fuentes, you haven't
been able to do so. Okay? Because as
I've mentioned, you haven't included the
wars. That's one aspect. you have not
included the wars. Another aspect is
that you haven't included why it is that
black people are in a disenfranchised
disproportionately disenfranchised
situation to white people at all. I
mean, if you think about when the
American Civil War took place was 1861
to 1865
from my recollection, this is when
slavery was abolished. Thereafter, I
think there's a 13th amendment of the
Constitution in the United States of
America that abolished slavery. But then
you still had indentured servitude for a
very long time. In England, I think it
was 1834 that they abolished slavery and
they actually abolished it before the
United States of America. But that's in
the formal sense. Indentured servitude
continues and you could argue slavery
continues to this day. But when you have
such a gen when you have such a gap in
prosperity between the whites and the
blacks, there's never been a kind of
slavery like this, by the way, where you
bringing people because of their race,
race-based slavery, and bringing them to
United States of America in those
environments. Now, let's just play fair
for a second. The historical analysis,
who should be who has a right to be more
feared uh from what racial group should
the white person be more feared from the
black or the black from the white? If if
you're a black person in the 1800s,
early 1800s, who should be will you be
more scared of the white man or the
white man be scared more of you? Okay,
so that that's one thing. You've got a
long history of the United States and
you're not including the historical
analysis. In fact, you are trying to
handwave the historical analysis off.
This is why your analysis, your
assessment is actually skewed. It's weak
because it doesn't bring in all these
things, all these factors, the colonial
factor, the slavery factor, the the
racial slavery factor. That's not just
any slavery. Most civilizations had
slavery. Okay, we're talking about
racebased slavery, racist slavery. Okay,
that was very peculiar to the United
States of American experience. That was
very peculiar and that's not being
factored in. And then you're not
factoring in the wars that the United
States engaged in afterwards. And you're
coming to this skewed conclusion that
yes, in Chicago and Detroit, yes, you
have black people committing crimes and
it's more so disproportionately than
white people. Well, how about this? Is
that the cause? is the cause that the
fact that they're black or not. Is this
a cause-based argument? Because if this
is a cause-based argument, you now have
to provide sociological and
psychological evidence. Now, I don't
think you'll be able to do that because
you're a dropout from university, isn't
isn't it? For let's be honest, you're
not academic. You haven't even finished
a bachelor's degree. Not even one
degree. Okay, you talk about IQ, but why
couldn't you finish your degree? With
all due respect, you couldn't finish
your degree.
Why? There's lots of black people in
America finishing their degrees from
more prestigious institutions than the
one you went to. Okay? So, you couldn't
finish your degree your degree. You
didn't do any peer-reviewed work. You
don't have any academics reviewing your
stuff. You don't have any thesis, any
dissertation, nothing. And and you're
coming out [laughter] and basically
making these and that's what it is. If
it I promise you any medium tiered
academic will be able to tear your your
arguments to shreds frankly because it's
actually quite weak. So Piers Morgan
should have and this is a point where
Nick Fuentes actually dominated uh I
would say uh Piers Morgan because Piers
Morgan couldn't understand the perap. is
playing dumb or all this stuff and he
does this thing where when he doesn't
know the answer to something he kind of
weasles it's a really weak situation for
him and this was the strongest moment in
the entire two hours for Nick Fuentes.
However, the responses to Nick Fuentes
on the arguments that he was making were
so many
are so many that can be made that uh
frankly I'm surprised that Pierers
Morgan couldn't master
the intelligence or couldn't think about
these things himself.
Uh and I've made this argument and I'll
finish with this argument. A cause-based
argument could more plausibly be made
for wealth socioeconomics. Black people
in America are more likely to be poor
than white people. If you're more likely
to be poor, you're more likely to commit
crime. Black people are more likely to
be poor. Therefore, black people are
more likely to commit crime. So, it's
not because they're black. It's because
they're poor. Okay? That's in Detroit,
in Philadelphia, and these places. If
you're poor, you're more likely to
commit crimes. That's why you hear
Billies in in the Bible boat. And I
think your a lot of your constituents or
your congregationalists or whatever you
want to call them, your friends and your
followers are essentially just basically
hillbillies. I mean, frankly, Mr.
Fuentes, your president is a hillbilly.
Your president, Donald Trump, is just a
hillbilly. That's what he is. He's just
a sophisticated or actually a business,
a rich hillbilly. That's what he is.
He's a rich hillbilly.
Okay? So your words might get through to
a couple hillbillies here and there in
Ohio or what Texas
but to be honest if you really start to
assess and employ some level of
criticality you realize everything
starts falling like a house of cards.
Now I could I could present this kind of
arguments to you and we can go back and
forth but you know and I know why you
haven't engaged with me even though you
have said you would. Let's play the clip
where he said he would and come back and
respond. When are you finally going to
chat/ collab with Muhammad hijab? Would
be a great convo. He's close with date
sne guys.
>> Does he have a big following? I don't
know that much about him. I really don't
have a ton of interest in talking to
like Muslim evangelists. But if he has a
big platform, I do it. I don't really
know that much about him.
>> So you see in that clip, he's talking
about me. He know he says, "Oh, I don't
know really know about Muhammad." But he
knows about me because he mentioned me
before with Sneo and he says Muhammad
hijab and Sneo and um you know messing
around with their pajamas and tom
foolery and something like I can't
remember the words he was using. It was
actually quite funny. He's a quite funny
guy. He knows who I am. Okay, stop
playing games. You know who I am. You
don't want to discuss. I'm not in I
don't want to I don't desire a hostile
engagement with you, my friend. Okay, I
just desire to challenge you on some of
your ideas because I believe that if you
keep promulgating and espousing the
ideas that you're promulgating and
espousing, it can cause actual violence.
It can cause hate. It can cause
division. And I think what we believe, I
as a Muslim and you as a Christian, is
that really what we should believe, I
mean, the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam told us there's no
superiority of a black man over a white
man, a white man over a black man, an
Arab over non-Arab, Arab, a non-Arab
over an Arab. There is no equivalent
thing like that in the Bible. I have to
be honest. But at least you said you
believe, okay, on the Piers Morgan uh
show, you said you believe that everyone
is equal, all the races are equal uh in
the sight of God. So if that's what we
believe, then what you're doing is and
your understanding or interpretation of
Christianity from wherever you got it is
wrong. Okay? And that's why we're
principally against what you're talking
about that the race-based stuff, this
cause-based arguments, this superiority,
the you're creating, you're talking
about black people being narcissists.
You're creating a generation of white
narcissists, frankly, thinking that
they're better than other people just by
the virtue of the fact that they have uh
less melanin in their skin or because
they're connected to a civilization
which they had no part of building.
Okay? frankly and there are little
hillbillies here and there and little
chavs in England. Okay. So, we can have
a discussion like this. I doubt you're
going to oblige because to be honest
with you, I think you pick your
opponents or you pick your interlocators
quite um selectively. You you avoid uh
places where there's going to be actual
academic argumentation and discussion,
okay, and challenge and where you can be
made a fool of or contradiction can be
shown. I doubt you're going to do it.
And I know that the message has come
gone to you because we've spoken through
Sneaker, we've spoken through Myron
Gaines and this and that and the message
has been and you've mentioned. So look,
if you're if you're not interested, I'm
not interested, frankly. Um, but I think
it would be interesting since I'm now
engaging with the far right in this
country. This will be an interesting
kind of addition to that. If you're not
interested, once again, I'm not
interested. I have no desire. But with
that, I will conclude witham.
Your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a masid, a
da center. This center, this masid, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light, calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam. So
give generously and Allah asawel will
give you even more.